In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God
to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity,
to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother, Mary,
and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires;
and may you, my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your Most Holy Will so intimately
that I may never swerve from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure,
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will
that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother, Mary,
to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light,
so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
So, we want to begin this evening with January the 30th, 1926,
and we begin with the announcement of the death of Father Francesco Devanadictis,
who was Louisa's spiritual director.
And we have this extraordinary situation that Louisa had been asking the Lord for years,
that the confessor shouldn't have to really come round, that was really a thorn in her side.
And then when she hears that instead, she goes into a bit of a crisis about it,
which is very interesting.
So, as she said, I was at the summit of my affliction because of the almost sudden death of my confessor,
so it was absolutely not expected.
To my many interior pains due to the frequent privations of my sweet Jesus,
he wanted to add such a painful blow to my poor heart depriving me of the one
who was the only person who knew my soul.
Now, to be stuck in a bed with nowhere to go, as Louisa was,
and to have somebody who actually understood her was an immense blessing.
So, when it is taken away, it is huge to massive trial altogether.
And if you think the Lord is going to be sympathetic,
just wait for the rest of the message, it's just unbelievable.
And again, it follows this thing that I've been telling you all the time,
that the Lord allows her to go through a crisis, and then he explains why.
And shows her what to do with it, and he's going to do this here as well.
So, Jesus won't be sending her condolences or anything,
but he will explain why this is happening.
And you will realize that everything that happens to us,
whether it's a bereavement or anything else, is all part of the divine plan,
and it is the best thing for us, the people who have gone on,
and the people who are left behind as well.
And so, she rightly says, "Made the fiat velontas,
to be always done, loved, and adored."
The earth was now worded to possess such a person,
which is a very high commendation of the priest,
considering the relationship that Louisa herself has with the Lord.
Therefore, the Lord to chastise us has brought him to heaven with himself.
Now, that comment I find is very interesting,
because Louisa has been asking the Lord for years to take her,
and doesn't see that that might have been a chastisement for the rest of us.
I mean, what would have happened to the whole divine will mission?
So, in my intense bitterness for having been left without my confessor,
not knowing myself to whom to turn, I prayed to my beloved Jesus
for that blessed soul, and said,
"And this prayer for him is really wonderful,
and we should pray it for all the souls and purgatory."
"My love, if you took him away from me, at least bring him straight to heaven with you,
and crying, I said to him, 'I place him in your will.'
We're being shown how to pray for the people who have gone on.
Your will contains everything.
It has love, light, beauty, all the good that has been done and will be done,
and made these purify that soul that we're praying for,
embellish him, enrich him with all that is needed in order to be in your presence,
so that you will find nothing in him which might prevent his entrance into heaven.
Every night, I prefer to pray that for all the souls and purgatory,
so that they're all brought forward.
I think it's the most wonderful prayer to pray for the dead.
Now, while I was doing this and saying this, a globe of light came before me.
Now, it's not often that Louisa actually says that a globe of light was put before her,
and for those of you who have been in my classes previously,
I have reminded you of Blessed Anna Maria Taige, who lived at the time of Napoleon,
and she lived a very impoverished life just literally at the gates of the Vatican.
And the Lord gave her the gift of a globe of light,
and people from very high walks in life like cardinals and bishops and princes and kings and emperors
and everything, they came to her for advice, and she would look into this,
and the Lord would show her exactly what was to be said to the person.
I remember just one case of this where a man of very high standing a layman came to her,
and he was expecting the Lord to tell him he was going to have great success in the future,
and the enterprises he was involved in was really great and all the rest of it.
And Anna Maria looked at him and smiled and said,
"I suggest you give up all of that."
The Lord has told me to tell you to get ready to go, your time's up.
I would imagine that had an absolutely unbelievable effect on him.
This globe of light, his God is light.
Sometimes he lets some of his favorites see in a way that the rest of us don't see.
So this globe of light came before me, Louisa said,
"And within that light, that is in the presence of God because God is light, one John, one five.
There was the soul of my confessor."
In other words, he was safe on the other side.
He was with God, and he was making his way towards the vault of heavens.
Now notice there is a journey on the other side,
and since Jesus tells us in these writings that 9 out of 10 people who die go to purgatory,
it means that the journey on the other side can be quite long.
And that's why prayer for the souls in purgatory has to be very persevering.
So he was making his way towards the vault of the heavens.
Without saying even a word to me,
he said, "I would imagine he was otherwise occupied."
I remained consoled, yes, because of his destiny,
but embittered the summit because of my own.
And I prayed to Jesus that since he had taken the confessor away from me,
that I myself had no one to whom to turn,
by his goodness he would free me from the bother I gave to the confessor.
Now she's kept this up for 18 volumes.
This is really a thorn in her side she does not give up.
And one of the things that fascinates me about Louisa
is that if she gets something like this into her head,
she doesn't let it go.
She has this very deep relationship with the Lord.
And yet she can hold on to something like this.
It's very interesting.
As long as we're on the earth, we're not complete.
Or as I heard someone say, you're an unfinished symphony.
When the last note was put in, then you're taken off.
So here she is again saying that she didn't want the bother of having a confessor.
I said it was Volume 1, it's really going on since Volume 2.
However, not because it was wanted by me,
but as something wanted by Jesus.
Now this is the cleverest thing you ever came across.
This is something she has wanted since Volume 2.
And now she says to the Lord, but you know,
what I want is that you will want it so that it's not just me that wants it.
I think that's a bit of a convoluted way of going around it.
Because I feel that if Jesus conceded this to me as something wanted by me,
I would feel as if I were lacking the earth under my feet,
the heavens above my head, and the heartbeat of my heart.
Correct.
You've gone back to square one.
You wanted something so badly that you were insisting.
So she actually sees the trap.
Now whether this is put here for our benefit,
well of course it's there for our benefit,
but whether in its primal sense it's there for our benefit,
I just wonder because human beings have this thing that we want to twist God's arm.
And because it's God's arm, we can say, you know,
God allowed it, God wanted it.
So we have to be really careful that when we pray
that we really are genuinely surrendering to God's will
and that we're not trying to manipulate him.
So from me, she said it would be a disgrace rather than a grace
to manipulate God to try and get him to agree to do your will
is a disgrace, not a grace.
And so all abandoned in sorrow, I offered everything to Jesus.
She realizes the trap that's there,
that he would give me the grace to do his most holy will in every thing.
See, that is the issue.
It's very easy to write it on paper.
It's very easy to say the words, but to actually do it in every single circumstance
of our lives, that's a different subject.
And for each one of us, we have different issues.
And we might surrender on nine out of ten of them,
but the tenth one is mine.
That's what I'm holding on to.
And so we can find ourselves struggling in areas that other people
wouldn't even think about.
But each one of us has an area, and this was Louise's one,
that she did not want the confessor coming to bring her around every morning.
And so Jesus sympathized with her in our sorrow,
last her all to himself and said to her,
"My daughter, courage, do not fear."
Now notice how frequently he tells her not to fear,
because I've told everybody, and I now notice I'm quoted all over the world for this,
which is fascinating to me, that do not fear is in the Bible 365 times.
You may not know where it originated, but it originated here.
I'm fascinated that people just pick it up and quote it,
but the frequency with which Jesus tells Louise not to fear
is fascinating to me as well.
So do not fear.
I do not leave you.
He's been telling her that since Volume 1, I do not leave you.
That's Joshua 1, 5, if you have forgotten all the references
I gave you in the early volumes.
I will always be with you.
Why? Because they are one.
They've actually reached inseparable union.
And I promise you that if no priest wants to make himself available for your assistance
and he has explained to her that because of the role he has given to her
as being the head of a new era in the history of the church,
that he wanted his ministers to be present.
The church had to be involved from the very beginning.
She just seemed to have caught that idea.
So if they don't want to make themselves available, not wanting to follow my will.
Now, there is Jesus very carefully explaining to her
that what she asked up above couldn't be his will.
She asks that the priest no longer comes.
She said, but I want it to be something that you want.
And he said he very gently and carefully says to her,
"If the priest doesn't want to assist you, he will not be doing my will
because he's explained very clearly from volume two
that it was his will that the priest would be involved."
So if the priest should refuse, I will free you from this bother of having them,
not because you wanted her because I myself wanted.
And that would be because the church has refused, not because Louisa has asked.
"Therefore, do not fear, for I will not let your will enter into this."
This is very important, but he's very carefully go round to what she said.
Why is he saying I will not let it because they have reached this inseparable stage?
At the stage you and I are at, I presume we haven't reached inseparability in saying this.
He wouldn't have this delicacy.
I will not let your will enter into this, I will do everything myself.
In other words, he will see to the priest, he will see to the need that is there,
and he will see to Louisa being cared for by the church, everything.
I will be jealous even of your breath.
Now we've dealt with all of this in the early volumes.
The jealousies of the Lord are very clearly expressed in Exodus numbers,
just to give you three books of the Bible, but I'm not going to give you endless quotes out of them.
And the Lord is jealous. Why would the Lord be jealous?
It's because he is the creator of this person.
He is the redeemer of this person. He is the ultimate goal of this person.
This person cannot live without him. He is the Alpha and the Omega.
Why wouldn't he be jealous of you giving your attention to something else?
When he's the source of all your good, all your life, all your destiny, all your glory, everything.
He's just everything.
And so for someone in the position that Louisa is in,
that she is to be the head of a new mission for him, a new generation,
even her very breath. In other words, there's not to be.
And it's expressed in that prayer we say before the reading and study.
So that I will remain so docile to the movements of your holy will, that you will not perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul
to your requests of me. That's what we're dealing with here.
Not even a breath of resistance, not even a thought, a consideration, nothing.
That your will may not enter into it, but only mine.
Now, since he's making this complete demand, that absolutely everything is to be committed to him.
He's going to explain why.
So if you have your volumes beside you, what I do is I put headings on the paragraphs
so that when I come back, I know exactly what I'm going to be reading.
And the heading I would put on this paragraph is the destiny of the world is on Louisa's shoulders.
That's why Jesus has to take care of every dot and tittle.
Then, when the night came, I felt such fear that blessed Jesus might take me by surprise.
That is, she goes into her ecstasy and she can't come out of it.
And make me fall into the state of my usual sufferings that I trembled and cried.
More so, since I felt as if I wanted him to free me.
You see, she's on this border, think of her human nature really wants something
and she is trying to keep her will out of it.
It can be very difficult.
It's like being extremely tempted to do something and you're walking a tight rope,
trying to keep away from giving in.
And blessed Jesus came out from within my interior.
And placing his face close to mine, he cried so much that I felt his face too wetted by the tears.
In other words, he sees the extraordinary struggle that she's actually having.
And he sympathizes with her.
And sobbing, he said to me, my daughter, have patience.
Remember that the destiny of the world weighs upon you.
I think that's unbelievable.
You see, she was chosen to be the head of a completely new era of humanity.
A completely new people of God were going to read that very soon.
And so the triumph of the two hearts of Jesus and Mary depends on her cooperation.
It's like when our blessed mother said her fiat at the age of 14,
that the entire future of the human race was on her shoulders.
So the sheer enormity of what God is asking of Louisa is stated here.
You do not know what it means to be in this state of pain together with me.
In other words, you don't know the value of it.
You kind of know in your head that it has some kind of value,
but you can't appreciate it because you need to be totally spiritual.
You need to be on the other side to really understand it.
He said, even for half an hour or even five minutes,
would you underline that for your own sake?
That's when you get the headache or the backache or whatever other ache you have,
that instead of running for the paracetamol, that you realize even five minutes with him suffering,
with him, in his will for the salvation of the world, that's worth everything.
We have to begin to understand this.
When I began to grasp this, it liberated me hugely,
because most of you don't know anything about me in any real sense,
but I've rarely been without pain since I was born.
And so it really helps to know that even five minutes with him,
and I actually put it on the cross as well, or in the agony in Gethsemane,
and in his will, it's worth everything.
It's really worth it.
It is my real life that's being repeated upon the earth.
That means we have a genuine participation in his passion.
It's not theoretical.
It's genuine.
And it's this divine life that suffers, that prays, that repairs in you
and transmutes my very will into you, so that it may operate in you as it operations in my humanity.
That's what's going on when we unite our sufferings with the sufferings of Jesus in the divine will.
But it must be in the divine will.
Our sufferings aren't much.
And you think this is trivial, Jesus said?
And keeping silent, he continued to cry.
He was trying to let her know how deeply grateful he is
that someone would join him for a couple of minutes.
And notice he said even five minutes, even a half an hour.
I think that's a plea from the heart of God to us to be generous.
I felt my heart break in seeing Jesus cry.
And I understood that he was crying for me to give me the grace that his will would have its full right over me.
So in this crying, Jesus is making intercession to give her the grace and the desire and the perseverance
and the motivation and everything she needed in order to be able to do this for him.
We can't do it by ourselves, John 15, 5, without me you can do nothing.
We can do it with him, Philippians 4, 13.
I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
So what is that issue here is that the divine will would have its full right in us.
That it maintain its life whole.
That it is, it's not broken within my soul.
And that my will would never have life.
So the Lord really intercedes for us because we're going to get a message tonight about the human will.
So the reason for his tears was to place his will in safety within my poor soul.
He intercedes for us so that the life of his divine will in us will be safe.
And he cried for priests in order to give them the grace to understand his works.
That they too would be willing to do his will.
Now that bit is rather interesting because it refers to what is at the beginning of the message,
which is that Jesus wants the priests to take care of Louisa.
So let's go to February the 7th, 1926.
And here Jesus tells us, don't do the rounds by yourself.
Take his divine love and love him with his own love.
Then your rounds will be very valuable.
I was fusing myself in the holy divine volition according to my usual way
and taking the eternal, I love you, of my sweet Jesus and making it my own.
So we're taking God's love and making it our own
and loving him in all of creation with his own love.
That's the level at which he wants us to do around.
Not just with our love, I mean what's our love?
Taking the eternal, I love you, of my sweet Jesus and making it my own.
I was going around through the whole of creation in order to impress this eternal, I love you, upon each thing.
So that everything and everyone would have one single note.
It would all be united in this eternal, I love you.
There would be one single sound and it's the sound of eternal love.
There would be one single harmony, which is love itself.
I love you, I love you, I love you, for myself, all and towards my creator, who so much loved me.
Now while I was doing this, my beloved Jesus came out from within my interior
and pressing me to his heart all tenderness he said to me,
"My daughter, how beautiful the I love you of one who lives in my will, I hear the echo of mine together with hers over all creation things."
So here's the echo of his own that he gave to the Father during his lifetime.
And what we're doing is we're picking that up and we're doing our rounds through him with him and in him.
It's wonderful.
I hear the echo of my I love you together with hers over all created things.
Therefore I feel there are quite a love of the creature for everything I've done.
And then to love means to possess what one loves or to want to possess that which is loved.
Like people who are engaged to be married, want to be married, they want to possess the beloved.
Okay, so you either have the possession you're already married or you want it.
Okay, but that's what love demands union.
And so you love the whole of creation because it is mine and I allow you to love it because I want to make it yours.
And you hear her often saying in your divine will everything is mine and the whole of creation is ours.
And that is the motivation for taking care of the earth.
Not the silly stuff that you hear the politicians going on with.
Your repeat is I love you for me.
Upon each created thing is the way to come to possession and begins to give you the right of possession as well.
So the more you do it, the more you take possession.
The right to possess them.
In feeling loved, all creation recognizes their master.
Now the next piece is a masterful description of Romans 819 where the true sons of God are recognized.
So all of creation recognizes their master because the human being was made Lord of the earth in creation.
And therefore they make feast in hearing your I love you being repeated upon them.
Love makes one recognize what is one's own.
And they give themselves only to those by whom they are loved.
Think of that now.
Think of that the next time you're sewing potatoes or vegetables in your garden.
They actually like being loved.
Those of you who do well with your plants know that as well.
I've known that if I want the plants to respond well,
I go and very very gently touch the leaves with my two four fingers like that.
Very very gently and tell them that I really appreciate them that I love them and they just bloom.
It's incredible.
I had an entire rose bush bloom in a week for me after I encouraged it like that.
So the Lord is telling us that it isn't just humans that respond to love.
It isn't just animals that respond to love plants respond to love.
Everything responds to love.
Why because the creator is love and they recognize the essence of love.
Not intellectually of course, but they respond.
So they give themselves only to those by whom they are loved.
And my will raining in the soul is the confirmation that what is mine is hers.
So God's creation responds to God's will in us reaching out in love to them,
which it has done since the beginning.
Now when something is in common between two persons, the highest accord is needed.
That means unity.
One cannot do without the other.
And here is the necessity for their inseparable union.
Now the Lord is saying to us that we're really not going too far in the divine will
until we come to this inseparable union.
You and me and I in you.
Making one.
Okay, this inseparable union.
And it's a union of continuous communications on what to do with what you possess.
You'll see this at the end of the Song of Songs.
Let us go and look after our vineyards because the vineyards are in flower.
And it is the two spouses, the two beloveds who actually go to look after their vineyards.
And whenever anybody has a relationship of union with God,
if that person is not involved in the work of God, it doesn't make any sense.
It's like parents who have no involvement with their children.
It doesn't make sense.
So there must be continuous communications of what to do with what we possess, so there's continuous communication going on between the soul and God.
Or how my will, reigning in the soul, raises her above everything.
And loving with God's love, she can love all things with his own love, with the divine love.
This is just very awkwardly translated there.
Loving with the divine love, she loves everything with God's own love.
And it's the continued possessor and queen of all creations.
So let's Romans 819 very wonderfully explained there.
So when we're reading this, we realize, of course, that we haven't reached inseparability.
We haven't reached this wonderful perfection.
And so in the next paragraph, Jesus explains that God's will makes up for our deficiencies, which is wonderful.
My daughter, it is in this happy state that I created man.
My will was to make up for all that was lacking in him and to raise him to the likeness of his creator.
Let's Romans 830 and it's Genesis 127, I think it is.
And this is precisely my aim upon you.
That is to give you this likeness of the Creator.
To make you return to the origin as we created man.
Now here the Lord is saying that in going deeper and deeper and deeper into the divine will, we're going deeper and deeper into the likeness of our Creator.
When we come to the next message, I think it's the next one, and we're talking about the human will.
Yes it is. Jesus will explain that the more we indulge in the human will, the more we go towards the likeness of Satan, the opposite.
And the human will tends to bring you towards darkness and the divine will towards light.
So this point is introduced here.
Therefore, I do not want division between me and you.
And that means on anything, on any point, nor that what is mine is not yours.
But in order to give you your rights, I want you to recognize what is mine.
So that as you love everything and your I love you flows over all things, all of creation may recognize you.
They will feel in you the echo of the beginning of the creation of man and delighting in it.
They will yearn to be possessed by you.
In Romans 819 Paul says that the whole of creation is longing to be restored, but cannot be restored without man being restored.
And that's what Jesus is explaining here that the creation will respond to us when we are indicating that the Lord has restored us.
So in the next paragraph Jesus is going to give an illustration and an explanation and is going to talk about himself as a king who has been abandoned by his own people and is ignored by them.
So he's going to be talking about a situation that is worldwide today, that is the worldwide apostasy that we're in.
I act for you, he said, like a king who is despised by his people, offended and he's forgotten.
These people are no longer under the regime of the laws of the king.
Now if I give you that in biblical terms, I go to Exodus 32.
The incident of the golden calf when Moses said that the people had broken loose.
That means they had broken out of the Ten Commandments and the parameters that God had given to us within which we could actually be happy and live with each other on the earth.
And to break out of that means to descend into horrible immorality and bestiality as well.
And so he says that he's like a king whose children are like that.
That's very much how it is today.
And if they observe any of the laws, it is force that imposes itself on them, not love.
Now notice it's not his kingdom if there's no love. If there's love, there is God.
We used to sing that where there is love, there is God.
And he's saying here, where there is no love, it's definitely not the kingdom of God.
And you'll notice that when apostasy takes over, that love grows cold and we are watching that terrible phenomenon today.
So the poor king is forced to live in his royal palace, isolated. That's the Lord, isolated in his tabernacle with the churches closed.
Without the love, without the subjection and without the submission of his people to his will.
But among the many he'd noticed that there's just one who maintains himself whole in letting himself be subdued entirely and completely by the will of the king.
In its initial context, that person is Louisa.
In the context of your country and your world, it's you.
The one out of the many that tries to live in his divine will.
Even more, this person repairs, that means make reparation.
He cries that's intercession for the rebellious wills of the people, the whole of the world.
And would want to compensate the king for making himself the act of each creature.
So this is the normal way that we pray in the divine will.
So that he might find in him everything that he should find in the rest of the people.
So in this one person who loves him, he finds that this person is making reparation for everybody else.
His compensating for everybody else is doing penance for everybody else, is interceding for everybody else to try and do something about the situation that's here.
So the king naturally feels drawn to love this particular one and keeps him always under his eyes.
That's Louisa isolated in the bed to see whether he is constant.
Now, this is actually a very important little point that when the Lord sees that we are actually serious,
like so many of us made a public act of consecration last August.
So that certainly would give the impression to God and to humanity that we were serious.
So if we're serious, then the Lord will keep a special eye on you.
He wants to find out if you're going to be constant.
Now, if you go to the Bible from the story of Abraham onwards, you will find that every servant of God that God has ever called,
he has tested them and tested them to see could he really trust them.
We can trust him, but we are in constant.
And so there has to be testings and there has to be trials to see are we spiritually road worthy, let's put it that way.
And not for one day, but for a period of his life, but that he would be constant for the whole of their life.
So the Lord wants to find out are you a season or a lifetime.
That means some people can be totally enthusiastic, but he wears off and they get tired of it and say, I heard that before.
We heard all this teaching before and they get tired of it and because they get tired of it,
they go from being fervent to lukewarm and maybe lukewarm to going out with the divine will all together.
That's really sad. So the Lord doesn't want us to be constant just for one day or just a period of his life,
but only constancy is what the King can rely upon.
That means that the person will be committed day in, day out for the whole of their lives.
That's what he's looking for because it's only those people that he can use to really change the world.
So that he can be sure of what he wants to do with the creature. So if we are faithful, God will decide I can use her for that.
I can use him for that area and he will cover all the different areas of need in his kingdom.
In other words, I have a soldier for that area. I have a general for that area. I have a teacher for that area.
I have whatever, whatever, whatever. But he's able to cover all the needs of his kingdom. But if we're not constant, he can't give us the job.
It's actually not possible.
So to sacrifice oneself to do good for one day is something easy.
But to sacrifice oneself for one's whole life, that is difficult.
And if it happens that it is a divine power operating in the creature, so when the King feels sure about him, he calls him to himself into his royal palace and he gives to him all that he would have given to the whole people.
So in other words, when this person has proven to be trustworthy, the Lord will then choose to give them a job that would actually change history, which is what he's doing with Louisa here.
It's what he did with Mother Teresa called Carter John Paul II and lots and lots and lots of others.
So he calls him to his royal palace. He gives to him all that he could give to the whole people and putting the others aside, he makes a new generation of his chosen people come out from this one.
This is very important because I'm not sure if this is the first time it was made this clearly to Louisa that an entire new generation of the people of God is going to come out of her.
That there will be a generation of people called the children of the divine will or the family of the divine will coming out of her.
So therefore you see why you had this long, long journey through these 18 volumes, why there were so many trials and so many testings.
So please do not think that you and I can reach some kind of fantastic stage if we have not been put through these huge testings by the Lord.
But if the Lord is putting us through testings and is purifying us and we're holding in there, we're letting him do it, then there is hope that he can use us powerfully for the future.
But if we're not accepting the testings and the trials, then you have decided yourself that you're not going to be one of his generals.
You've decided yourself you're not going to be a significant person in his kingdom because you're not letting him actually train you.
I've not been tried and tested severely to see am I air worthy and could anybody put their lives at the risk of letting me take them anywhere.
Huge, long, long, long years of purification before it and it continues. The purification doesn't finish because if you go this far, he'll bring it to the next bit.
If you go there, he will bring it to the next bit. If you go there, he'll bring it to the next bit.
It's actually terribly important. So he will make a new generation of his chosen people come out of this one. In other words, this one has obeyed his divine will and he wants a whole generation of children who will do that.
"Behold, I will make all things new," he said, Revelation 21.5. And also look up Isaiah 43 verses 18 and 19. Isaiah 65, 17. "I will make all things new what he wants is to create a generation of people who will actually live the kingdom of God on earth." That's what he's aiming at.
And so this generation of a new chosen people will have no other ambition than to live of the divine will, that is of the king alone, all submitted to him like many parts from his womb.
Think of the chosen people that were given to Moses. Think of the new people of God that were given through Jesus. Think of the new people of God among the Gentiles given to the twelve apostles.
Think of founders of religious orders and a whole generation of people was given to them. If you consider, for example, just the Franciscan order alone, St. Francis lived at the end of the 11th century.
And his generation of people are still there today. It's amazing. And so think of other trees of Calcutta who followed an inspiration of the Lord to do something. And now the generation of her children are all over the world.
It's the one religious order that's in every country on earth, all the Muslim countries. Most of the others are not in Muslim countries.
So here we have Louisa realizing what is meant by the world is leaning on your shoulders. So Jesus says to her, "Don't you think my daughter that this is precisely what I'm doing for you?
My continuous calling you into my will so that not yours but mine will live in you. My wanting from you that you will let me find the note of your, I love you, of your adoration of your creation, of your reparation for each offense upon all creation things from the first to the last man that will come.
Does this not say in clear notes that I want everything in order to give you everything? In other words, you have to live this life perfectly if the others are going to follow you because you'll be a model.
And that raising you above everything I want my will to be restored in you whole. That is complete. There's no bits of human will left. Beautiful. It's not tainted by anything to do with the human will or self. Triumphant.
He has won the victory over us. Just as it came out of us in the beginning of creation. My will was the prime act of the creature.
Now, you know that the church has always taught us that God is the prime mover. He is the first mover. We can do nothing unless he moves.
What he's saying here is that if he was the prime act inside of Adam, then his acts were divine, but they were coming out of divine will.
And therefore the divine will wants to do its course, the course of its life inside of her. And even though the divine will was suffocated in its very first arising. That's the fall of Adam in the creature. It was not extinguished.
And therefore the divine will awaits its field of life in her. So the divine will is still waiting for this generation of children. And we are at the beginning of that generation of children. It's really wonderful.
But think of the people in the future who will be born into the time of the divine will have it from their infancy, which would be wonderful.
Therefore be attentive. When you want something, never do it on your own. Now, if you have your book with you, this needs a green, white and gold covering.
Or let's take it out of the page and stick it on your fridge. If you're going to do something, never do it on your own.
But pray to me that my will will do it in you. In fact, that same thing, if you do it by yourself, it sounds bad. It gives of the human.
But if it's done in my will, it sounds good and it harmonizes with heaven. And it is sustained by a divine grace and power. It is the creator that operates in the creature.
It's fragrances divine and rising everywhere, it embraces everyone with one single embrace in such a way that all feel the good of the operating of the creator in the creature.
I read that quickly because it's a summary of what we've been reading many times before. Let's come to the woodworm of the human will.
It's by comparison with what we've just read that the woodworm of the human will stinks.
And you'll see why Jesus puts stuff about the human will after he's told you something utterly divine about living in his divine will.
Because it's only when you compare the two that the reality of the destructiveness of the human will comes home to us.
And we need to be reminded very often because we can slip back into the human will without even realizing it.
So, Louisa said, this whole paragraph now is the seriousness of shifting out of the divine will that you can, in one moment, you can slide down the ladder or you can fall off the cliff.
So, I was thinking to myself, why is there so much fear in me to the point of feeling my life is missing in me?
May this never happen that I might not do the holy will of God entirely and completely.
Now, the two things there that are extremely important are the words entirely.
And the other one is completely.
You see, we're all prepared to do the will of God, but it may not be entirely.
There may be a little bit of me in it, and it may not be completely.
And so, they're the two words that are the most important.
The mere thought of this destroys me, Louisa said.
What would it be then if I came to the point of withdrawing even for a single instant?
Do you remember Jesus said he'd be jealous even of her breath from the supreme and adorable will of my creator?
Now, while I was thinking of this, my beloved Jesus came out from within my interior and taking my hands and his, he kissed them with unspeakable love because his love is divine.
Then he pressed them so very tightly to his breast and all tenderness he told my daughter how beautiful is my will operating in your hands.
Now, notice he's taken her hands.
Your emotions are wounds for me.
You hear me saying this very often.
The word wound for us has a slightly different meaning, but we know what they're trying to say here.
But they are divine wound because they come from the depth of my will, dominating, operating and triumphant in you.
So, they touch him deeply, but those touches are divine touches.
I prefer to call them touches because that's what the other spiritual writers, including Saint John of the Cross, calls them, the divine touches.
And so, I feel wounded as though by another me with just reasonably a fear, he said.
If you went out of my supreme will, even for one instant, how low you would descend.
Now, when you're looking at the gospel, you realize that a man who was called to be an apostle, not just a disciple, a man who worked miracles in the name of Jesus,
a man who preached him to the crowds, fell so low as to sell him for 30 pieces of silver, and to cause him to be tortured to death.
And so, the human will can really drag us down in the most awful way.
"Oh, how low you would descend," he said, "you would reduce yourself as though from the state of Adam innocent to Adam guilty."
And since Adam had been created as the head of all generations, and Louisa is the head of this new generation of divine will children,
his will, withdrawn from his creator, formed the woodworm in the root of the tree of all generations, and what Jesus is saying to Louisa is,
you're the head of a new generation, and if you went out of the divine will, even for one instant, none of the others could come completely.
It wouldn't be possible further, just as we were all born with the stain of Adam's sin.
Therefore, all feel the ruins which the woodworm of the human will formed from the very beginning of the creation of man.
Each act of the human will, not connected with that of God, forms an abyss of difference.
You see, we have no idea of the extraordinary distance between the human and the divine.
We can say the words, but we can't really grasp it.
And he says an abyss of difference, so that we will have some way of grasping it.
So each act of the human will, not connected with that of God, forms an abyss of difference between the creator and the creature.
And therefore, this abyss of difference in terms of sanctity, beauty, nobility, light, it says science, that usually means knowledge, understanding, etc.
So I want to give you a Hosea for six that without this knowledge, with understanding the people perish. And that's what's happening today, all around us in society, that we're watching the people perish without divine knowledge.
Okay, so by withdrawing from the divine will, Adam did nothing but put himself at a distance from his creator.
And every time we do our own will, even in the smallest things, we are putting a distance between ourselves and the creator.
We're making the journey longer for ourselves and we're making it harder as well, because the more we give into the human will, the harder it is to put it aside.
Because we know that we're not even talking about sin, we're just talking about human will, but we know that sin is literally insanity.
It unbalanced him completely and caused imbalance in all generations.
Now we know that imbalance in a person causes illness and we do know that out of the fall of Adam came sickness in death and hell, the four great enemies of the human race.
It caused imbalance in all generations because when evil is in the root, the whole tree is forced to feel the malignant effects, the bad humors which are in the root.
Therefore, my daughter, since I have called you to be the first and to be the head of the mission of my will, this will of mine must lay in you the balance.
You see the opposite of the imbalance, the balance between you and the creator and to remove the distance which exists between the human will and the divine.
Otherwise, the rest of us can't follow. So is to be able to form in you the root of the tree without bad humors, making only the vital humor of my will flow so that the tree may not be jeopardized in its growth in the development and the preciousness of its fruit.
Therefore, Jesus is trying to ensure that the children of the divine will will start from a very wholesome root and that the tree of the family of the divine will will be a very wholesome family as well.
Okay, so it's eight o'clock, but I'm going to finish this message. Is that all right? In the next paragraph, we have a new chosen people of the divine will.
So we're going to talk about the divine will family now. It's beautiful.
Now, if you wanted to do an act of your will, Jesus said, not connected with mine, you would come to form the woodworm to the mission, the entire mission because she's the head, which I haven't trusted you.
And like a second Adam, you would ruin the root of the tree of my will, which I want to form in you, and you would jeopardize all those who will want to graph themselves onto this tree.
Romans 1124, that we are the ones who want to graft ourselves onto the tree of the divine will. And if there's something wrong with it, we can never know wholeness or fullness.
So, Louisa is getting very clear instruction as to how extraordinarily serious it is for her to have even a breath of resistance to the divine will.
So, I'm pointing that this is in the prayer we pray before reading and study so that you will understand the importance of that statement.
Therefore, Jesus said, "It is I who cast this fear into your soul so that my will may always be dominant in you, and all the manifestations which I have made to you may always be in growth."
Okay. Now, if you look at Proverbs 9, 10, the fear of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom. Now, fear is not this sort of terror stuff. It's not that at all. It's that you would understand the gravity of what you're doing.
You would understand the gravity of your decisions and that you would therefore be able to make much better decisions than you would before.
And when you have to really put yourself aside, say, "Now, listen, the consequences are big. Do this right."
So, the divine will must be always dominant in Louisa and all the manifestations which Jesus made to her would always be in growth in order to form the divine root, trunk, branches, flowers and fruits without the shadow of your human will.
Now, Jesus himself formed the tree of life in his own life, his passion, death and resurrection, and now he's using exactly the same image talking about Louisa as the beginning of a new people of God.
In this way, you will return to your origin into the womb of your Creator, all beautiful, grown and formed with the fullness of the divine will. And the divinity satisfied in you of the work of the creation of man would make its new chosen people of the Fiat Belontas tour on earth as it is in heaven.
So, when this work is completed in Louisa, then he is forming the seed of the new people of God in her.
And so, this new chosen people will come out from you and from the mission that is entrusted to you.
Therefore, be attentive, my daughter, and do not want to ruin the work of my will in you. I love it so much and it costs me so much that I will use all my infinite jealousies.
Now, I want to give you Exodus 20, verse 5, and Exodus 34, verse 14 for the infinite jealousies.
I myself will guard my will so that yours may never have life. So Jesus is saying that he's got to take massive care of Louisa in order to be able to take care of us.
So, in the next paragraph, we have the seriousness of acts done in the human will and this is definitely for us. This is something we really need to look at because we can slip back into the human will without realizing it.
Because we're not in the concentrated environment that Louisa was in. We don't have spiritual directors visiting us every single day.
We don't have the Lord appearing to us and we don't have divine revelations made to us on a daily basis, so we do not have the help that she had.
So, it's much easier for us to fall back.
Louisa said, "I remain surprised and I understood with such clarity what an act of the human will actually means compared to an act of the divine will and how the soul by doing her own will loses the likeness of her creator."
Again, Genesis 2, 7 and Romans 8, 30. So, she loses the likeness of her creator and stripping herself of the beauty with which she was created.
She slips back from the beauty of holiness to the ugliness of selfishness.
She glodes herself with miserable rags. That's the selfishness that we get back into. She barely drags herself in good. She acquires the diabolical likeness.
I think that statement really, really needs to be taken out of the book and put in a place where we see it clearly.
That every time I fall back into the human will, I am acquiring the diabolical likeness, whereas when I surrender completely to the divine will, I am acquiring the divine likeness.
The divine likeness I should have given to you before is to Corinthians 3, 18. That we are changed into the image that we reflect.
And Jesus is saying it works the other way around as well. And she feeds herself with dirty foods that's human stuff with all its low, lowness.
My Jesus gives us all the grace never to do our own will, which is like calling all the passions back to life.
Now notice that the moment you go back to letting the human will dominate, then all the passions get into action and you're back into the basic struggle again.
But Jesus gives us the grace and the power to stay up in the divine will. So almost trembling, Louisa said, "I tried to plunge more deeply into the supreme will, and I called my celestial mother to my help so that together, in the name of all, we might adored the supreme will on behalf of all the human will opposed to it."
So notice her instinct is immediately to make reparation for what the human will is doing.
Now, while I was doing this, the heavens opened and my Jesus came out from within my interior, 1 Corinthians 3, 16, Kingdom of God is within you, all in feast.
And he said, "Daughter of my volition, you must know that when my will reigns in the soul, it integrates everything she does."
Now it integrates everything, physical, mental, emotional, and spiritual, you become whole.
Now it doesn't happen overnight, but one of the ways in which you will know you're growing in the divine will is that you become aware of the fact that you're becoming more and more and more whole.
W-H-O-L-E, and you have to be W-H-O-L-E before you can be H-O-L-Y. And so it integrates everything she does and the development of the life of my eternal will in her.
So everything in your whole being, this temple of God that he has made, integrates with the divine will.
And of course it all operates according to the divine will anyway, because we can't do anything without the divine will enabling it.
So it was not you who called my divine mother, but it was my will that called her.
So Jesus is explaining how the thing works.
And she feeling called by a divine will, which has always been whole and triumphant within her, immediately perceived that one from the celestial family was calling her upon the earth.
And that's magnificent. So if we're in the divine will, then the divine will is calling her to come and help.
And she realizes, "Oh, it's one of my divine will children this calling." It's magnificent.
We really need to read that over and over. It's very beautiful.
She immediately perceived that one from the celestial family was calling her upon the earth.
And she said to all in heaven, "Let us go. Let us go. It is one from our family that is calling us to fulfill the duties of the family to which we belong."
One of our divine will family on earth is calling the divine will family in heaven to fulfill their duties towards us.
Isn't that a wonderful way of seeing prayer?
And also seeing the extraordinary power that someone living in the divine will has. And here they are. Look at them all around us.
Jesus said, "The blessed virgin herself, the saints, the angels, a to do the act of adoration that you want to do and the divinity to receive it."
Wow.
So in this final paragraph, Jesus says that the divine will is the key to heaven and self will is the key to hell. Choose.
My will has such power as to enclose everything Jesus said and to make everyone do the same thing as if it were one single act, which of course the divine will is one singular.
Hence the great difference that passes between one who lets my will reign within herself and one who lives of her own self.
We've been looking at that all the time, the massive distance between one and the other.
In the first one, there's a divine will that prays, a divine will that operates, a divine will that thinks, a divine will that looks and a divine will that suffers.
So, it's God Himself that is looking out towards others to draw them.
It's God's will that's operating through us to speak to them.
It's God's will that is and God's love that's operating through our heart to love them. It's wonderful.
At each motion of hers, the divine will moves heaven and earth and connects everything together in such a way that all feel the power of the divine will.
Operating in the creature and recognize in her the nobility, the likeness, the offspring of their creator.
So, there's your Romans 819 fulfilled and as daughter of the celestial family, all protect her, all assist her, all defend her and long to have her together with them in the celestial fatherland.
Please underline that if you have the book. They're all on your side if you're living in the divine will. If you're living your own will, you're on your own.
Your guardian angel will mind you and try and get you into the divine will.
All the opposite for one who lives of our own will, which is the key to hell, the key of miseries and of inconstancy. Whatever place it opens, it can open only there where evil is.
Because you see, the self will won't get into heaven.
And if she does any good at all, it's only apparent because inside of it, there is the woodworm of her own will, which gnaws at everything.
Very wonderful image because the woodworm is eating away into the wood destroying your furniture all the time.
Therefore, even if it should cost you your life, never, never go out of my will.
It's a wonderful way to stop this evening and I thank you for coming. God bless.